i want to start with
two questions that i really want you to
think about
and the two questions are what should
i be afraid of today
and who's to blame
what should scare me and whose fault is
it
to me these are the most
profoundly dangerous questions that we
center our lives around
um and what they are indicators
to me with their indicators of is a
culture of scarcity
a culture of not enough and when you
think about
think about any milieu in your life
think about education
what are we supposed to be afraid of and
who's to blame
politics the economy social issues
i guarantee you if you turn on the news
or open to paper today
the focus would be here's why you should
be afraid and here's whose fault it is
and it and what's interesting to me
about that
is it's not just at a cultural level or
a community level
that stuff happens in my house every
week
every week with my husband i talk to him
about what we should what should be
you know why we should be fearful and
whose fault it is mostly it's his
but you know if something doesn't go
well at my daughter's school
then i'm like oh my god this is
this is going to have huge implications
for our university
and we should be terrified right now
that she's not getting cursive i know
she's four
but this is still relevant it's
indicative of scarcity so let's talk
about what scarcity culture is
and what it looks like scarcity culture
i think is best understood
with a simple question of never enough
and you can fill in the blanks never
good enough
safe enough certain enough perfect
enough
relevant enough and perhaps i think one
of the most dangerous
and insidious messages today is never
extraordinary enough
somehow in the world we live in today
an ordinary life has become synonymous
with a meaningless
life um and it has
huge i mean and i've watched it happen
not only as a researcher i'm a
qualitative researcher so
i sit across from people and look in
their eyes and i have a good sense of
what's going on their lives
but as a university professor who's been
teaching for the last 17 years
it's been very clear to me that
extraordinary
means relevant and the top one is
is the big one for all of us personally
never good enough
you know which is shame which we all
have on occasion that sense
that we're not smart enough good enough
perfect enough loved enough promoted
enough
we're not enough so what we do in
response to scarcity culture
i think all of us every day
is this we wake up in the morning and we
armor up
and we we put it on and we say i'm gonna
go out in the world
i'm basically just going to kick some
ass i'm not going to let anyone see who
i
am and in doing so i can protect myself
against the things that hurt the most
judgment criticism
fear blame ridicule i'm gonna armor up
and i'm gonna be safe and we rationalize
and we convince ourselves
that this armor is really smart
and we use a lot of different things to
armor too perfectionism
intellectualizing
[Music]
but if you get really really clear
about what we're doing every morning
when we wake up and decide to armor
it's this simple
this is what we're protecting
we're protecting being hurt
for a very simple reason that no one
really wants to talk about which is this
love belonging irreducible needs of men
women and children
in the absence of love and belonging
there is always suffering and so what we
believe is that we can protect our sense
of being lovable and being acceptable
and being worth connection with armor
here's the very worst news from my
research
the news that above all other i did not
want to hear
is simply this and i don't even want to
say it to you because i think it's mean
to say it
but it's so true and it's simply
our capacity for wholeheartedness
can never be greater than our
willingness to be brokenhearted
which is a terrible thing
but a truthful thing
that we can only love and be loved
as much as we are willing to have our
heart broken
and so when we move to the world like
this
and with our partners with our children
with our friends
in classrooms with the people who work
for us with the people we work for
there are tremendous casualties my story
is
that i'm i am a researcher and i never
thought i would have a big public career
and so i did a ted talk that went very
viral
and in the wake of that
i was kind of everywhere for a couple of
months on every cnn.com
npr it was everywhere and something i
wasn't used to
and the marching orders from my
therapist and my husband were do not
read the comments
online so i read all the comments online
and so one morning i woke up and there
were
two or three new articles out and i
started reading the comments
and they were devastating um they
weren't about my work they were about me
they were super personal
and they were the things
that creative people play in their mind
and then give up doing what they really
want to do like if i
asked every single one of you
you would try what would you try
if you knew people would never say this
about you
what would that what would this be it
would
those were the comments that morning um
of course she embraces imperfection what
choice does she have look what
look at how she looks um i feel sorry
for her kids
less research more botox
just mean personal attacks the things
that really
up until that moment had
inspired me to stay very small in my
life in my career
just so i could avoid those things so
that morning steve and the kids leave
i stay home i get on the couch
and i watch eight hours of downton abbey
and when it's over i don't want to turn
off downton abbey
because i then because the minute you
turn off downton abbey then it's like
soccer practice and dinner
and back to the mean people and maybe
should i get botox and
maybe you know maybe if i stand still
when i talk um
so i get my laptop and i do a search for
who was president in the united states
during the downtown abbey era
have you ever done that like you're
numbing with tv or a movie and so when
it's over you just like
stay in that space by like learning more
about the actors
and what's going on um i've been doing
this long enough to know this is like
you're laughing with me not at me um
so i put it in and theodore roosevelt
comes up and a quote comes up
and i read it and this is what it says
it's a quote from a speech that he gave
in the early 1900s that this were born
and
a lot of people called the man in the
arena speech and this is the passage
that changed
changes my life it's not the critic who
counts
it's not the man who points out how the
strong man stumbles or where the doer of
deeds could have done it better
the credit belongs to the person who's
actually in the arena
whose face is marred with blood and
sweat and dust
who at the best in the end knows the
triumph of high achievement
and who at worst if he fails he fails
daring greatly
so the moment that i read that i closed
my laptop and this is what shifted in me
three huge things first i spent the last
12 years studying vulnerability
and that quote was everything i know
about vulnerability
it is not about winning it's not about
losing
it's about showing up and being seen
the second thing this is who i want to
be
i want to create i want to make things
that didn't exist before i touch them i
want to
show up and be seen in my work and in my
life
and if you're going to show up and be
seen there is only one guarantee
and that is you will get your ass kicked
that is the guarantee that's the only
certainty you have if you're going to go
in the arena
and spend any time in there whatsoever
especially
if you've committed to creating in your
life you will get your ass kicked
so you have to decide at that moment i
think for all of us
if courage is a value that we hold this
is a consequence
you can't avoid it the third thing which
really set me free and
i think steve my husband would argue has
made me somewhat dangerous
is kind of a new philosophy about
criticism which is this
if you're not in the arena also getting
your ass kicked i'm not interested in
your feedback
period good i've just never done
anything that's turned out to be
valuable that wasn't just
scared less to do it like everything
i've ever done that's ever
really made a contribution i have felt
alone in doing it and afraid
and but alive yeah that's a really
interesting
go tell me more about that alive
alone but alive that's it's sort of like
the wilderness
it is the wilderness because the
metaphor for the book is let's see if i
get this right yeah rather than asking
you i'm going to try and
check my work um there's it's there's a
poetic narrative about it's being
wild and risky and you have to prepare
to go there and it's
it's also stunning and
so there's an obvious really clear
connection between that and putting
yourself out there there's risks and
rewards and beauty
but there's interesting twist if if i
get this right that
it's not that you are in the wilderness
it's that you
are the wilderness explain that well i
think
what i what i have found is that after
the first time and it only really takes
one time
after the first time that you opt to
brave the wilderness you
pull away from what a group of people
thinks maybe it's your maybe it's your
creative community it's your critics
the first time you pull away and find
power and standing on your own
i think your heart is marked by the wild
i think you belong
in into the wilderness in a different
way because every time
after that when you choose fitting in
over belonging to yourself
it's painful i want to start with the
maya angelou quote that you share
you are only free when you realize you
belong
no place you belong every place no place
at all
the price is high the reward is great
let's dig in with what does true
belonging mean and
why this message why not you know maya
angelou has been my most
steadfast counselor for my entire life i
discovered her probably 30 years ago
when i was in college
and i lean into her work you know how
when you find those people that just
are inspiring and honest in their work
but they also bring you joy and comfort
she's that for me and i love everything
she does
except for that quote that quote has
pissed me off for decades and i never
understood this idea that you're free
when you belong nowhere
and as a social scientist i know that
belonging i know this
for sure like if you ask me the one
thing i know for sure 200 000 pieces of
data
i know in the absence of love and
belonging there's always suffering
that i know for sure so this quote from
her about belonging everywhere which is
really nowhere
is what sets us free was so troubling to
me
but then i started digging in and i
started trying to understand
what does it mean to belong and i never
thought of the concept of belonging i
thought belonging was like
we have a crew like like a posse yeah a
squad
and and belonging to something you kind
of negotiate with external groups of
people
but it's not what i found very quickly
is
the rest of that actual quote is part of
an interview that she did
where she ended with bill moyers where
she ends up saying you know he ends up
pushing a little bit
on and saying so are you saying that you
belong nowhere and to no one and she
said i belong to maya
and what i found is that true belonging
is a spiritual practice and it's about
the ability to find sacredness
in both being a part of something but
also the courage to stand alone
and the people for those of us who
struggle to have the courage to stand
alone
especially when we know that at risk
we're risking
that sense of being a part of something
because we disagree
yes because we have a different opinion
because we love something different that
is the mark
that's the mark of true belonging to be
able to say yes i am a part of something
bigger but i also will stand alone when
i need to
and then then it was like oh
you belong everywhere and nowhere and
that is liberation the biggest myth
about
vulnerability is that it's weakness i
think a lot of people were
raised to believe that it was modeled i
think certainly in our culture
we see that a lot that to be vulnerable
to be open
to be exposed is to be weak and the
truth is
you know what i found in my research is
that vulnerability is not weakness in
fact i would argue that it's our
greatest measure of courage
when we went out and asked people what
is vulnerability we heard things like
vulnerability is the first date after my
divorce vulnerability is starting my own
company
vulnerability is taking responsibility
for something that went wrong at work
vulnerability is sitting with my wife
who has stage three breast cancer making
plans for our young kids
vulnerability is taking my business
public
you know the definition i use in my work
of vulnerability is simply
uncertainty risk and emotional exposure
vulnerability is about the willingness
to show up and to be seen
even when there are no guarantees and
it's interesting to me i mean one of the
things that i thought was really
interesting i gave a talk
it's probably a couple years now and it
was being translated by
people doing american sign language and
they came up before the talk started
they said
are there any words that you're going to
use a lot in your talk that we should
you know know about that it might be
different i said well i use the word
vulnerability a lot
and they kind of there were two of them
they kind of looked at each other and
they said oh we we do this for
vulnerability
and i said what does that mean they said
it means weak in the knees and i'm like
wow that's not how i talk about
vulnerability and she said
well there's only one other sign for
vulnerability and i said what is it and
she said
and i said oh that's what i'm talking
about and so
to me vulnerability is our most accurate
measure of courage i mean it's pretty
powerful when i have 13 000 pieces of
data
collected over 12 years that i cannot
find a single incident or story of
courage
that was not completely underpinned by
vulnerability
i think the problem arises that there's
so many little paradoxes with
vulnerability and one of them is
that vulnerability is
courage in you but weakness in me
when i meet you it's the first thing i
look for in you but it's the last thing
i want to show you in me
and so i think to really put ourselves
out there knowing that if we do that
enough we're going to fail
i just don't think it gets more
courageous than that if i roughly took
the people i interviewed
and divided them into people
who really have a sense of worthiness
that's what this comes down to
a sense of worthiness they have a sense
a strong sense of love and belonging
and folks who struggle for it and folks
who are always
wondering if they're good enough there
was only one variable that separated the
people who have a strong sense of love
and belonging
and have a strong and really struggle
for it and that was the people who have
a strong sense of love and belonging
believe they're worthy of love and
belonging
that's it they believe they're worthy
and to me the hard part of
the one thing that keeps us out of
connection is our fear that we're not
worthy of connection
with something that personally and
professionally i felt like i needed to
understand better
so what i did is i
took all of the interviews where i saw
worthiness where i saw people living
that way
and just looked at those what do these
people have in common and i have i have
a slight office supply addiction but
it's another talk so i had a manila
notebook a manila folder and i had a
sharpie
and i was like what am i going to call
this research and the first words that
came to my mind were wholehearted
these are kind of wholehearted people
living from this deep sense of
worthiness so i wrote at the top of the
manila folder
and i started looking at the data in
fact i did it first
in this very four in a four day
very intensive data analysis where i
went back pulled these interviews pulled
the stories pulled the incidents
what's the what's the theme what's the
pattern
my husband left town with the kids
because i always go into this kind of
jackson pollock crazy thing where i'm
just like
writing and going and kind of just in my
researcher mode
and so here's what i found
what they had in common was a sense of
courage
and i wanna i wanna i wanna separate
courage and bravery for you for a minute
courage the original definition of
courage when it first came into the
english language it's from the latin
word ker
meaning heart and the original
definition was to tell the story of who
you are with your whole heart
and so these folks had very simply the
courage to be imperfect
they had the compassion to be kind to
themselves first
and then to others because as it turns
out we can't practice compassion with
other people if we can't treat ourselves
kindly
and the last was they had connection and
this was the hard part
as a result of authenticity they were
willing to let go of who they thought
they should be
in order to be who they were which is
you have to
absolutely do that for connection
the other thing that they had in common
was this
they fully embraced vulnerability
they believed
that what made them vulnerable made them
beautiful
they didn't talk about vulnerability
being comfortable
nor did they really talk about it being
excruciating as i had heard
earlier in the shame interviewing they
just talked about it being necessary
they talked about the willingness to say
i love you first
the willingness to
do something where there are no
guarantees
the willingness to breathe through
waiting for the doctor to call after
your mammogram
the willing to invest in a relationship
that may or may not work out they
thought this was fundamental
i'm going to tell you the story of how i
get to the best definition of boundaries
from a creative
kelly ray roberts artist portland
um she's an artist who self-trained she
was an oncological social worker
um like being a social worker in
oncology hard work
she taught herself to paint now she has
a thriving huge business
um and she was teaching art classes and
people were copying her art and selling
it
and selling it on etsy and selling it
different places
and one day she wrote a blog post
and it was about boundaries and she said
let me tell you what's okay and what's
not okay
and she made a list of everything that
was okay it's okay if you copy my art
hang it in your house
it's okay if you download one of my
paintings and use it as
a little sticker on your website as long
as it's attributed
it's okay if you do this it's okay if in
good spirit you do this and this
it is not okay if you do the following
five things i love it
and it was the most the clearest
example and i called it i'm like you
just pulled some
social work magic [ __ ] on air and
she goes yes it would be so helpful if
creatives were all social workers
because
we're trained and here's what's okay and
what's not okay you can come to my party
love to have you you can't get faced
yeah
you know and that's a hard conversation
so i think one of the reasons why or
for creatives the biggest thing i run
into and i work with creatives all the
time and interviewed them
just almost exclusively for rising
strong
is people are afraid to put value on
their work
that's so true people are afraid to
charge for it people are afraid to hey
look i know you're a really good
photographer can you come
and shoot this wedding
for yeah for nothing for zero dollars
yeah for just like a free
quiche and you know whatever if you're
serving
no because you do you know how stressful
it is when you get do you know what
happens
when you get to a wedding things don't
go well i've never shot a wedding in my
life
because the concept of the mother of the
bride is
way more frightening to me than google
like head of advertising with you it's
like
for the people who do that that is
that's a stressful out of work
right and so the answer is i'd love to
shoot the wedding
um this is my fee for doing that
oh man come on i'd really love to but
you know because if you don't put value
on your work no one else will
if you want to see the affirmations
video for success with mel robbins check
it out right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there and because
you're only ever going to do the things
that you feel
like doing right now or that feel good
right now